[Music]
this higher language that of tragedy
gathers closer together the dispersed
moments of the individual essential
world in the world of action the
substance of the divine in accordance
with the nature of the notion sunders
itself into its shapes and their
movement is likewise in conformity with
the notion
in regard to form the language ceases to
be narrative because it enters into the
content
just as the content ceases to be one
that is imaginatively presented
the hero is himself the speaker and the
performance displays to the audience who
are also spec spectators
self-conscious human beings who know
their rights and purposes
the power and will of their specific
nature and know how to assert them
they are artists who do not express with
unconscious naturalness and naivety the
external aspect of their resolves and
enterprises as happens in the language
accompanying ordinary actions in actual
life
on the contrary they give utterance to
the inner essence they prove the
rightness of their action and the pathos
which moves them is soberly asserted and
definitely expressed in its universal
individuality free
from the accidents of circumstance and
personal idiots in idiosyncrasies
lastly these characters exist as actual
human beings who impersonate the heroes
and portray them not on the form of a
narrative but in the actual speech of
the actors themselves
just as it is essential for the statue
to be the work of human hands
so is the actor essential to his mask
not as an external condition from which
artistically considered we must abstract
or so far as we do have to make
abstraction from it we admit just this
that art does not yet contain in it
the true and proper self
here in paragraph 733 we are now making
a transition from one form of language
to another form of language
in this section on religion and so we we
do need to keep in mind that we're not
just talking about
art for art's sake nobody created epics
tragedies comedies just for the sake of
doing them and they were not you could
say
a totally independent domain
of human life as they were being
developed they were
developing not just with religious
content you know gods doing things
heroes who are sort of like god let's
you know little gods in some respects
sometimes often you know demigods
children of gods
they were part of greek
religious life particularly
tragedy as we're going to talk about
so
as we're going into this incredibly
important paragraph where this
transition is happening
it's probably worth spending a little
time talking about what we know
about greek tragedy the sort of things
that hegel would have had in mind
and would have taken for granted in his
educated readers that we might not have
all of us available
at hand today we might not have learned
these things
so
we're talking about two different forms
of what we nowadays
call literature one of which we often
place into its own category and we'd
call drama
or theater
and when we look at these things in an
academic context these are often like
different departments right so for
example
i first encountered sophocles
oedipus the king in a
world literature class when i was in
college i just hadn't read it up until
that time i'd heard about it and you
know heard about sophocles i i don't
think i had actually read any sophocles
until i was in college and we were
reading it we were not actually seeing
the play
performed
and there's a vital difference there
that we're going to get to
in a moment
aristotle is a helpful person to bring
in at this point because hegel of course
like any educated person at the time
knows aristotle's poetics which is at
least in book one
about what tragedy book two which was
lost was supposed to be about comedy
maybe someday we'll find it but until
then we don't actually know what was
being
said in there and aristotle very
helpfully provides us with
a short history
of the development of greek tragedy
he's not saying that it was just epic or
hymns or stuff like that and then
tragedy emerged completely out of that
that's that's not the case the situation
is more complicated than just moving
from one form directly into another but
one thing that we do know
about aristotle or from aristotle and uh
the history of tragedy that ties in
directly with this paragraph
is the nature of
the
actor the
now when we we hear that word actor it's
related to act right they are depicting
action although you know when you read
greek tragedies a lot of the action
actually happens
off of the
uh stage it's not
directly depicted we hear this oh horror
this has occurred right and
then we find out it's it's more words
for the actions that are coming out but
the actor as we're going to see
is somebody who steps up on the stage
behind a mask we'll talk about the
nature of masks in a bit as well
and
embodies doesn't just represent but
embodies
the
hero or some other character as we're
also going to see in the paragraphs to
come
there's another important function that
of the chorus which we're going to leave
out for the time being but let's mention
just for the moment that
some of the earliest dramas according to
aristotle had one or two actors and then
a chorus and when we say chorus they
were in fact not just reciting things
but singing right so there's there's
some other elements to it as well there
is a stage there's some
spectacle uh there's some music there's
some other important things but
aristotle isolated the most important
elements as being thought the annoya
right expressed through what the person
is saying
and then the actual plot the account of
what's going on
and this
is going to lead us to what hegel is
talking about the very beginning of this
and what he was talking about in the
previous paragraph the necessity how
does the necessity
and how does the concept the griff the
notion
play itself out
what function does it have
now as time went on tragedy became more
complex
and you know it's debatable about when
tragedy went downhill you know nietzsche
thinks that it's with euripides because
it becomes too socratic uh most people
will generally say well the the three
great tragedies were
echelous you know you might think about
the agamemnon right and the entire
orestea series
esophagus solidly in the middle and then
euripides and then it's you have new
tragedy with people like agathon
mentioned in the symposium a lot of
which we've lost right we only have
little fragments of that sort of thing
and comedy was also developing at the
same time as a matter of fact in
aristophanes we actually have a battle
between tragedians
that that's laid out
and there's old and new comedy we don't
have to worry about all those ins and
outs but suffice it to say
for hegel all of this back history is
hanging there in the background of what
he's saying so this transition from one
form of language to another
is playing out within that important
context and this is a context that helps
us understand
our own relation to the gods if we're
back then
tragedies were not something that you
would pick up and just read you know
actually i mean reading at that time
would be unrolling a scroll it wouldn't
be looking at a book like this but it
was something that you would
you could read it they could be read
aloud but generally you would see it
performed
you know we might say analogously that
listening to music is definitely not the
same thing as picking up the score or
the chords or the tablature and saying
oh this looks like a really great song
right now tragedy of course is language
can convey much more in written form
than say music can in its notation but
there's still something missing when you
don't have the
let's call it the human actor element
so
i think that's probably enough to say
about tragedy at this point there is one
other remark i do need to make
we use this word tragedy in a very loose
sense these days so
somebody spills their starbucks uh drink
and it gets on their their you know suit
uh before the job interview and they
muff the interview as a result oh that's
a tragedy
no that's not a tragedy from the greek
point of view that is just an
unfortunate
experience you know uh that's bad luck
right
that is not the same 2k is actually
there's a word for that sort of thing a
mishap right it's not a tragedy you need
more to have an actual tragedy and some
of this is hinted at in the previous
paragraph right with the middle term of
the hero the individuality of the hero
who however in his strength and beauty
feels his life is broken and sorrowfully
awaits an early death right
that's not the only way to do tragedy
but certainly there has to be a conflict
aristotle thought that somebody mighty
and high has to be brought low through
some some flaw some hamartius committing
some wrong despite not wanting to commit
wrong
and you know sometimes it can be a
little bit more difficult to explain
this you know you think about the
antigone does this neatly fit
the the schema probably not but it does
give you an idea that tragedy
is about
important things and it involves
conflicts that exist between different
values different courses of action
which are legitimate and have to be
taken into account with each other this
is going to come up again later in
the paragraphs to come
so
let's talk about what's what's going on
in this section that's a lot of preamble
hegel says this higher language right
horsebraca
that of tragedy so this is this is a
higher language than even the epic which
is a higher language than the hymn the
oracle the frenzy so we're kind of
ascending right this higher language
that of tragedy
gathers closer together the dispersed
moments of the inner essential world and
the world of action now that's that's a
very interesting thing to say so let's
pause on that
what is it gathering together
as we we just said here
the inner essential world what is an
inner essential world well
characters
whether they're gods or people human
beings
they have an interiority and they bring
out that interiority
through
language
also through the actions that they
engage in we see them choosing acts not
choosing why that tells you something
about how they view things
but they explain themselves they unveil
their mind before us right and this
happens in epic too right
at the very beginning we have achilles
you know talking to his fumo saying
should i kill this guy agamemnon or
shouldn't i kill this guy right because
he's stolen my my prize
actually the the tale begins you know
tell us oh muse of the wrath of achilles
wrath being externalized is
bringing this this out of its
internality right
uh the inner essential world and the
world of action the world in which we do
things and this isn't just a world in
which we do things this is a world in
which we do things and other people see
those things and they like cooperate
with it or they respond to it we're
gonna punish you for doing this this
thing right um so there's a back and
forth with the world of action sometimes
the gods get jealous of human beings for
their actions and now he says well
before we do that so gathers closer
together this is an important
phrase
this higher language and notice that at
first this higher language we're going
to come back to that in the epic is that
of the minstrel who is just mentioned in
the previous paragraph
who is the minstrel who is this the
zanger
in tragedy it's the playwright who also
doesn't just
write the play
out of their mind
they also have to
instruct the actors
and the chorus
in how to do it how it's supposed to be
performed right anyway coming back to
this this higher language gathers closer
together
fast
zoo
right brings together
you know
gathers is is a good uh
idea for it um with also the sense of um
assembling right assembling putting into
a kind of order
neher brings closer
together
what does it bring closer together the
dispersed moments the moments that have
been
falling apart from each other and
assuming
their own shape and in the epic the epic
is kind of
compared to tragedy
a
you know more messy disjointed kind of
thing you know and
nietzsche picks up on this later on
in his uh early as he calls it to
hegelian work the birth of tragedy
could be useful to take a look at that
and how nietzsche frames the tragedy as
opposed to the epic as well so he says
it gathers these together the substance
of the divine the good liken right the
god-like
sunders itself into its shapes
now that's an interesting
way to talk about things we'll get we'll
get to that in in a moment into its
shapes it's gestalten
um it's
forms it's types of consciousness we
could even say right
now
prett ausanander so the substance of the
divine
is actually
sundering
itself
right it is splitting itself into things
so that we've got a gathering and a
differentiation
right
it's
stepping out into different
forms
it is literally um
breaking itself into two pieces
so he goes on and he says
their movement
is likewise
in conformity to
uh the the notion right
he
the substance of the divine does this in
accordance with the nature
of the notion and it's just nature
uh des berges
the concept so as we saw in the previous
paragraph the
necessity is no longer just a void
there's a necessity which is becoming
not just intelligible
in the way of like understanding
feshtand
it's becoming conceptually
intelligible
and not just
representationally
intelligible there's something
going on in tragedy that has an
intelligibility that we have to work to
wrap our minds around it is a complex
intelligibility that is involved with
the concept there
so he goes on he says now here's there's
a discussion here a form and content
that we want to look at
in regard to form the language ceases to
be narrative because it enters into the
content so there's there's this
form work that's entering into the
content what is the content the actions
the words the relationships the form is
the way in which we're actually
depicting things how we're
how we're presenting things and then in
turn
he says the content ceases to be one
that is imaginatively
presented
so there's an interplay going on here
between form and content that is
incredibly important
and what is this
interplay
we're going to get to that in a moment
has to do with what actors are doing
right so it's not just what the
tragedian
is doing it has to do with the
people that the tragedy and is working
with
now um the form
is no longer just narrative er zealand
right something that is related
as the minstrel or the rhapsode would be
doing with epic telling the story right
and telling the story in a particularly
poetic way very often with some gestures
and intonation and stuff like that
the content is no longer
ein for gestalter right it's no longer
something that is merely represented
uh imaginatively presented as how
miller is translating it here and that
doesn't mean that this is going out the
door right it's not like nobody narrates
anything in a tragedy as a matter of
fact as i just mentioned a lot of times
the action happens off screen or off
stage you could say and somebody comes
back and they're like ajax just fell on
his sword you know oh woe is me what a
terrible sight i have seen right well
that's narration right and there is some
imagination going on within this there
is a four gestalin going on in this as
well but we're transcending that in in
some way
how are we doing that
well this is where we get to what's
distinctive about tragedy and drama in
general
he says
the hero is himself the speaker so now
it's no longer the minstrel the bard
the zenger who's the speaker somebody's
been put on stage to speak
the hero is not just getting lines that
somebody else is
saying the hero then said blah blah blah
blah blah
the hero is speaking himself from the
stage or the heroine antigone right is
is also a heroine
we have many
like that and he says the hero is the
speaker
and the performance displays to the
audience very important part here
the audience who are also spectators
okay so we've got two different
modalities being
sort of referenced here
the audience the zoo
and this is in the singular but it can
be you know generalized to a plurality
the audience is one who attends to one
who listens to one who hears
what is being said but they are also
spectators they are also lookers just
shower right they are they are seeing
what is happening you know take a look
over there shout right uh
pay attention to what's happening so
modalities of of listening modalities of
watching and now notice what he says
about this audience the audience are
self-conscious human beings who know
their rights and purposes
the power and will of their specific
nature and know how to assert them
right so the performance is displaying
to the audience
something about the hero and the
characters that they
themselves
are you know self-conscious human beings
who know their rights and purposes you
cannot you know let's take creon i am
the king you gotta obey me antigone uh i
i gave you an order don't bury your
brother because he's a traitor right and
antigone said well i've got a right to
i've got a right to
you know treat my brother lovingly
but the audience
are also coming into the place
as people
who have who know their rights who are
living viewer clique actual
human beings right
he goes on and he says they are artists
who are artists
the actors depicting the characters
who do not express with unconscious
naturalness
and naivety the external aspect of their
resolves and enterprises what it is that
they're aiming at what they're trying to
do they don't just express the
external aspect as if we are looking at
them in a painting or something
or as statuary
in a mosaic would be another great
example or on on vases right think about
ancient vases
so he says as happens in the language
accompanying ordinary actions in actual
life when we're doing you know ordinary
life we're like well i got to go to the
store
and get some butter why you got to get
the butter well because uh
you know i'm gonna make a cake and uh we
also want some butter for the popcorn
should you get salted butter or unsalted
butter should you get the generic uh
brand or should you get you know a more
expensive fancy brand you know
well i guess it depends on how i want my
cake to turn out for the popcorn it
doesn't really matter if it's not salted
butter i can put salt on it this is all
humdrum crap right
this is exactly what hagel's talking
about and the audience comes in and for
the space of the time that they are
attending to the drama they're leaving
all that crap behind
they're paying attention to
something
more as aristotle pointed out more
universal
it says
on the contrary they the actors give
utterance to the inner essence
they prove the rightness of their action
the rightness of the action of their
characters they justify themselves even
the ones who are kind of skeevy or
cowards justify themselves they're like
well everybody's you know kind of a
coward when you get down to it again
think of the antigone in the guard who's
like
oh man i don't want to go to creon and
give him this bad news because people
who do literally shoot the messenger
so these are justifications that are
being given
and he says
the pathos which moves them is soberly
asserted
definitely expressed in its now notice
this term
universal
individuality
what is a character
a real character
not just in drama but we could say in
literature as well has something
universal about them
at this point in time i'm teaching a
class on ursula kayla green's fantasy
earth sea
novels and short stories and when my
students read
about you know ged
the young wizard in a wizard of earth
see or
about arja or tenar in the tombs of
atuan they don't
think they're good they don't think that
they're ten are and this is in a very
different universe than we inhabit in
which dragons exist and magic happens
and has
particular ways of structuring and
there's old powers of the earth that
tenor is actually a priestess of um
since you know five years old
but we can see something in there we can
be like well ged is this kind of
character that's universality
embodied in individuality
it goes on
free from accidents of circumstance and
personal idiosyncrasies like all these
you know slobs in the audience coming
along and watching this to become a
really good depictor an actor means
giving space in yourself to the
character
now look at the last thing he says
these characters exist
as actual human beings who impersonate
the heroes and portray them
not in the form of a narrative as was
the case in epic
but in the actual speech of the actors
themselves
just as it's essential for the statue to
be the work of human hands
so is the actor essential to his mask in
ancient greek comedy and tragedy and
you've seen some of these masks
actors would wear big masks and that
allowed you to figure out who was who
right and they would then
behave in a way so it wasn't about like
facial expressions
uh or
i mean gestures played an important role
no doubt but especially because we had
you know big areas in which people were
doing things you might think about what
happens at concerts when like you know
instead of just standing there and
playing their guitar you know the person
like leans into it and strums the those
are gestures not for the front row
but for the back row to display what is
happening and actors would do that but
they're wearing the mask they have to
embody through their voice through
their
speaking through
how
they provide
you could say a space
for the hero or the anti-hero or whoever
to come through so he says uh the actor
is essential to his mask not as an
external condition from which
artistically considered we must abstract
or so far as we do make abstraction from
we admit this just this art is not yet
contained it at the true and proper
self
the mask is
less who the character is than the
performance of the actor and this takes
us back
to
an earlier paragraph you should remember
in the very end of the living work of
art
where we were talking about the dancer
within the temple right the actor
is doing this on a higher level
through language
and through movement and through their
engagement with the
other actors so that we have a genuine
tragedy
bringing together all these dispersed
moments the substance of the divine
representing itself within the interplay
between characters and an audience
who is engagedly
paying attention
to this and learning something
about if not themselves certainly what's
happening with the characters
you